let's speak to a few more people we take
calls via Discord on Fridays at
davidpackman.com
Discord that's the place to do it let's
go to Harry from Columbus Ohio Harry
what's going on there
can you hear me well uh I can hear you
let's put it that way
okay I'll be very brief and I'm very
excited for your new Finance Channel I
saw you dropped your first video
yesterday
multiple videos on the finance channel
the audience is responding sort of
mildly positively which I think is as
good as you can hope for on the internet
you know
yeah I agree so I'll be real quick okay
now I know very very little about you
know buying a house securing my assets
anything like that yep with the recent
raises in interest rates from the FED
does it make any sense to buy a house
until those come down like I have no
idea what calculations I need to make
before well here's the general thing a
tiny bit of advice yeah that's it thank
you so much here's the general thing
okay as a general rule and we have a
clip coming out on the finance Channel
about this when interest rates go up
home prices come down they tend to move
in opposite directions now it's not
always literally true sometimes interest
rates going up might just mean home
prices are steady instead of going down
but the idea is interest rates and
prices move in opposite directions and I
explain why in a clip on the finance
Channel which will be out very soon so
if you were in a position
to buy a home cash
High interest rate environments can be
good moments to do that now of course if
you're selling and buying often you're
you're subject to the same the same
market conditions that make buying
attractive might make you have to sell
your house for Less so it really depends
on the market and your personal
situation and whether you're only
looking to buy or buying and selling but
the principle at play is in general
interest rates up houses down
yeah it seems like I'm gonna have to
make a pretty you know big Financial
story a pretty big mortgage change to
get into uh a house so it doesn't seem
like it's gonna be the right time for me
if you have a mortgage at two and a half
percent right now and in the new place
you would need a mortgage at five
percent it may not be the right time for
you that's perfectly reasonable
okay thank you for the call very much
appreciate it mortgage rates complicated
stuff complicated stuff which we
absolutely will be dealing with on the
finance Channel